[Music]
my name is aj joyner owner of advanced
pressure washing llc
today we're going to show you how we
clean the exterior of a client's dirty
home
step by step
we in general we offer exterior cleaning
but the main services in the residential
field are
house washing gutter clean out
concrete cleaning those are the main
ticket items that we solicit to the
residential client
[Music]
the condition of the fence structurally
is great
but as you can see it's covered in
built-in algae wood is very particular
because if you uh
use too much pressure they're going to
cause a lot of damage to the surface
so to treat it we just use water we
actually use moderate pressure we make
sure
always to go with the grain this keeps
us from furring
slash damaging the wood
the driveway is terrible covered in
mildew and algae
the chemicals we normally use is called
sodium hypochloride 12.5
or better known as pool shock slash
industrial bleach
uh we normally delete that down to 50 50
ratio in our buckets
this kills a million algae that top
layer when we pre-treat
it kills almost instantly
this is called a whisper wash big boy
surface cleaner
that metal tubing actually rotates
around
on a swivel that's the item that i use
to actually clean concrete
from there we'll actually go around
washing the trim
of around the brick and other areas the
surface cleaner couldn't reach
and then we will post treat with the
detergent again to get
any organic stains that are left behind
[Music]
after we do the driveway we'll then do
the front patio and sidewalk
also sometimes if the client wants we'll
also do the curves along the drive
[Music]
the house is in pretty good condition
but there was a few spots that we
noticed that were pretty bad with
heavy and thick mildew and algae on a
house we use
roughly about 10 percent sodium
hypochlorite
uh mixed with about 90 water
so the black on the brick is actually
milled just really thick mildew and
algae
this is caused by moisture and shade
allowing for such big building algae to
grow
[Music]
when we wash a house's exterior we wash
the roof the outside of the gutters the
side of the home
the windows the doors anything that's on
the side
or attached to the home itself
[Music]
so we're finished we finally got the job
done uh so roughly this job took us
about
uh four and a half hours everything
looks
amazing the client was beyond happy with
the job that we have done
you clearly see everything is
transformed into a new clean
state my personal suggestion instead of
trying to do it yourself
is to always hire professionals because
you're dealing with some very strong and
dangerous chemicals
and it can become dangerous when in the
hands of someone
not experienced
you